there can be only one
magical
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
was i speeding officer
you don't look like you're from around
here no sir
you've been doing any drugs tonight no
sir
nope
don't you pop that trunk step out of the
vehicle for me please
really
[Music]
no drugs huh
nope
well well well
what have we here
no no no no no no you planted that in my
car oh
did i
uh
or did i plant this uh i
i guess the car right now oh spread them
uh
huh let's go whoa whoa what do we have
here huh what these are colors homie
that's that's something oh no i don't
know what that or are these your colors
or perhaps these are your colors
or are these look at all these colors
man you sure got a lot of colors look at
all of these colors
are you a real cop freeze what is that
well well well
it looks like an illegal firearm
or
is it
oh
i'm i don't i don't know what this is
i'm sorry pick a card
it's not even a good fan any card you
can just stick there okay you took that
card yeah now can you remember that card
yes can you commit that card to memory
this is unbelievable have you done so
have you yes please insert the card back
into the deck randomly done it's in a
different place than where you took it
originally
there we are there we are now
i take the deck like so i give it a
sloisals and abercross royce
is this your call no are you sure i want
your badge number
oh
how did you do that
and
that is for you
after all that you're still giving me a
ticket is it a ticket
or
is it a two-for-one coupon for my show
at the magic house thursday night at 11
pm
your call
i'll take the ticket
oh no please don't say anything please
just keep it to yourself whatever
oh
thought you had an idea i do
we need to make an app
like for a smartphone an app that all
the people could download and then we
make millions this is hard to come up
with man it's like catching lightning in
a bottle i already got that
you got what lightning in a bottle
really what's the idea
no no idea
i got actual lightning in a bottle no
levi that's just a phrase
i got that dog
lightning in the bottle blip that's
crazy son what'd you get that some old
chinese man sold it to me years ago
i mean that's some supernatural
man all it does is this
i got it
but seriously man
would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite television shows are
on no
we got to address this crazy ass bottle
that you got
a bottle
what bottle
the bottle
what's the lightning in it
you still on that
yes
how does it work cedric i don't know
it's the classic lightning in the bottle
guys classic
you just open it
okay you know what you shouldn't have
this
this belongs to the military or
something
but that app though no we don't need the
app you've got the goose that laid the
golden egg
how do you know about hunkers
[Music]
what
this mother
honkers
get in on this app idea you like it
he likes it
yeah he got a goddamn golden head
honkers here is the cat's pajamas
no please don't don't i want to show you
something whatever it is i don't want to
see it it's relevant i already know what
it is it ain't what you think
well what i think it is is a pair of
cats pajamas
these are for honkers to wear the what
the little neck in there the neck
how you gonna fit his head
through this with the the orange
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave my
house
why because you disrespected
my roommate
okay
okay it's clear that this is a crazy
house so i gotta go you over here
talking about geese the golden eggs and
feline sleepwear
oh man cedric
you need to get off your high horse man
hey i just thought of a name for you
high horse
but babe
moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage
huh
can i take your garbage yeah sure
you know
i find
the more garbage in the can
the better it feels to dump it all out
i suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here to fix the copier
yeah sure sure
hey how did you sometimes things
ain't really broken
it's the way we treat them
it needs to be fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is
who are you steve
well
if it isn't mr stanley
carl
you need to find your own troubled white
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
i was here first
[Music]
sweep this
[Music]
magical
[Music]
good lord
are you all right
well
i guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again
oh
you're a magical negro too
who you call a negro [ __ ]
[Music]